Gambier is an artist from Indonesia who
is shot to fame and wealth because of
his strange artworks he mostly makes
sculptures of pregnant women and some of
them look incredibly Eerie it's almost
as if he is hiding something beneath
them despite this Rich customers love
his work and are ready to pay a hefty
amount for it one day Gambier organizes
an exhibition of his portraits several
people come and appreciate his work in
awe but Gambier seems to be distressed
about something he is not satisfied with
how his life is running so he walks out
of the exhibition and starts smoking
right then his wife thailiada approaches
him and inquires if anything is wrong
out of nowhere Gambier starts
apologizing to her saying he did nothing
wrong here we get to know that Gambier
is disturbed by something which will be
revealed later in the movie The
Following morning Tyler and gambier's
Mom dala can be seen discussing his
illness from their conversation it is
revealed that Gambier has been suffering
from a disease that is hindering him
from being a father sometime later while
having breakfast the door bell rings and
Gambier rushes outside to have a look he
finds no one but notices the phrase
tolong soya written on the floor which
means please help shocked Gambier looks
around the place once again but there is
no one the same day while Gambier is
returning home after playing tennis with
his friends he remembers an incident
with taliada the scene then shifts to
the past when taliada and Gambier were
in a relationship but still yet to be
married surprisingly she was already
pregnant Gambier wanted to keep the
child but Tyler requested an abortion
this scene indicates that Gambier was
fertile before marriage he tries his
best to convince his girlfriend against
this drastic staff but she still won't
listen in the end Gambia reluctantly
takes her to a hospital and they abort
the child after the procedure the doctor
wraps the child's corpse in a polythene
bag and hands it over to the couple when
they return home Tyler makes a strange
request to Gambier she explains that
although they lost their child she wants
to preserve its Memories by keeping the
corpse with her as expected this blows
gambier's mind and he straight out
refuses the Sinister idea but even after
a lot of effort he's unable to convince
his weird girlfriend so in the end he
agrees to preserve the corpse and start
making a pregnant woman's statue when it
is complete he hides the corpse inside
of it one day a guest visits gambier's
home and takes a look at the pregnant
woman's statue surprisingly he likes it
and comments that it's a work of art
Gambier immediately reveals this to
thailiada and the latter suggests he
make more statues of pregnant women so
that they can attract a lot of customers
Gambier agrees right away but Tyler
gives him one more order all the statues
must have a fetus inside of them there
is no logic behind this but just Faith
she says once again gambiero bays and
starts preparing the statues from that
day onwards he also visits the clinic on
a daily basis and secretly buys deceased
fetuses to his Good Fortune the statues
start getting recognition among the
buyers and soon they go out of stock
seeing his progress and to expand the
business Tyler's Father Bill a large
exhibition hall for Gambier and Gifts it
to him he then starts working as the
company's manager and also marries Tyler
to Gambier the scene then shifts back to
the present where Gambier is busy making
some pregnant sculptures right then one
of his tools accidentally gets kicked
under a huge wardrobe and he has a hard
time retrieving it after a bit of
struggle Gambier somehow manages to
slide the Wardrobe but to his surprise
there is a secret door behind it he
tries to break the lock on the door but
before he can do so Tyler arrives and
stops him she tells him that if he
breaks the door then everything between
them will be ruined and disappear this
scares Gambier and he stops right away
but after a while Tyler puts a large
painting over the door to keep it hidden
following this Gambier simply carries on
with his work as if nothing has happened
next we are shown a young boy lying on
the floor with his hands and legs tied
with rope it is evident that his parents
have been treating him badly it is also
revealed that he is the same boy who
wrote the phrase tolong soya outside
gambier's house asking for help the
following day while Gambier is with with
his friend Dan dong in a cafe he cracks
a fortune cookie and finds a note inside
it simply reads look right Gambier
immediately turns right and notices the
same phrase toulong soya written on a
wall outside the restaurant shocked he
bids his friend goodbye and walks out
later Gambier is playing tennis with his
friends when he once again finds a note
placed on his bag with tolong soya
written on it annoyed he asks his
friends if they're behind it but none of
them speak up right then he notices the
same boy staring at him from the door
Gambier tries to get a closer look but
the boy simply runs away elsewhere we
are shown live footage of the little
boy's house where his mother forces him
to eat dinner and beats him mercilessly
when he refuses any order sadly rather
than saving his son the little boy's
father also starts kicking him with
anger meanwhile searching for answers
Gambier arrives at the same wall outside
the restaurant and removes some posters
from it under them he finds the phrase
written asking for help alongside the
name of a building hirosa say Gambier
immediately starts searching for the
building and finds it after a while it
appears to be a club of some sort he
then enters hirosa say and approaches
the receptionist surprisingly the latter
is not pleased to see him and she
instructs the security guards to escort
him away it turns out that only the
members of herosace can enter the
building and explore it although Gambier
is disappointed that he couldn't explore
the place he is adamant that he'll find
some Clues there so he keeps lurking her
out one day while keeping an eye on the
herosace building Gambier notices his
friend Dan dung entering the club a few
hours later dandong walks out and
Gambier immediately asks him about the
building however the sketchy friend
refuses to answer anything it's almost
as if something really spooky is going
on inside hence left with no other
options Gambier finally decides to
become a member himself after meeting
with the manager and registering himself
Gambier is provided with a personal room
with a TV the TV has a card with a list
of different channels Gambier carefully
selects one of them and sees an old lady
sewing her own hand to a perplexed he
quickly changes the channel and comes to
a halt when he notices the same boy that
he sought the tennis court the boy is
staring at the camera and is being
punished badly by his mother Gambier
watches the disturbing scene for a while
but when he can't take it any longer he
walks out of the building outside he
meets Dan dong who reveals that the
cameras are secretly placed by the
herosace club and that there is nothing
they can do to save the victims however
Gambier is deeply affected by the way
the little boy's parents treat him hence
he decides to search his house and save
him in the following days Gambier starts
visiting the club regularly where he
watches the same boy being punished by
his parents with each passing day he
becomes weak and this badly affects
Gambier the latter tries to find Clues
on the little boy's location but doesn't
even come close one day Gambier holds
another sculpture Exhibition at his Hall
and invites a lot of guests as usual all
of his artworks are sold within minutes
but surprisingly some guests can be seen
talking about the same boy who is
regularly mistreated this indicates that
these guests are also a part of the
notorious herosace Club one of them
reveals that he watched the boy being
drowned by his own mother and now there
is very little hope of his survival
meanwhile another guest talks about how
the mother's going to electrocute him
soon that's nothing man I heard they
were gonna force him to watch a mukbang
marathon Gambier who is hearing all of
this from a corner becomes upset and
rushes out of the exhibition Hall
shortly after he arrives at the herosace
club building and enters his assigned
room wasting no time he turns on the TV
and anxiously switches the channels to
find the boy fortunately he manages to
find him the boy is strangely calm he
stares at the camera and apologizes for
what he is about to do Gambier feels
very bad for him but can do little to
help meanwhile the little boy grabs a
kitchen knife and heads towards his
parents bedroom then in a shocking turn
of events he finishes his parents off in
an act of Revenge I knew the mukbang
marathon would be the last straw as
Gambier watches in horror the boy
commits the unthinkable after everything
goes silent a distraught and beer Falls
to floor regretting that he could not do
anything to save the little boy sometime
later he gathers himself and again
checks the TV card to his surprise he
finds his wife's name there and
immediately switches the channel to
watch her Gambier sees Tyler and his
mother dala but it is a pre-recorded
video rather than a live feed in the
video the two ladies discuss gambier's
inability to Bear children and how it is
going to be a problem in the future
deila even encourages thailiada to have
intercourse with other men so that she
can bear Offspring in particular she
wants her to make out with gambier's
close friends surprisingly instead of
refusing her strange request taylorada
obeys and sleeps with Van dung later
Gambier also watches the video of
taliada and her father conspiring
against him to take a considerable chunk
of his profit from his business this
finally reveals that thailiada never
loved him in fact she was always after
his wealth and fame her father also
joined in because he wanted to get rich
meanwhile After figuring out everything
Gambier becomes really angry and decides
to to take revenge he has a plan in mind
that will make all the perpetrators
regret their actions shortly after
Gambier walks out of the building and
calls all his relatives to celebrate the
upcoming Christmas Eve together after
this he meets a shady looking man and
buys an illegal gun from him Gambier who
is Rich and Famous is ready to risk it
all just for the sake of Revenge the
scene then shifts to Christmas Eve where
Gambier welcomes several guests to his
home he has decorated the place very
well with a large Christmas tree in the
corner furthermore to make the occasion
more real he has also prepared an exotic
dinner by himself after everyone has
arrived Gambier heads to the kitchen to
fetch some wine for them but before
returning he spikes it with a poison
called devilish pit as soon as the
guests drink the wine they become
paralyzed for 10 minutes they can see
hear and smell everything but cannot
move or utter a word with this Gambier
finally shows his true colors and grabs
a knife he then singles out each
relative and explains what they did to
wrong him as everyone looks on in horror
Gambier approaches one of the guests and
finishes him off in this way he berates
and then kills all of the guests one by
one by this time the entire dinner table
has become a bloody mass at last his
beloved wife thailiada is the only one
left Gambier decides to go easy on her
and brings out the gun but thailiada who
has now started speaking a little tells
Gambier that if he kills her he will
never be able to find out the secret
behind the hidden door hearing this
Gambier contemplates whether he should
pull the trigger but just then he starts
having flashbacks of all the men she has
made love with this angers Gambier and
he shoots Tyler dead immediately
following the massacre he rushes to the
hidden door and removes the painting
covering it he then breaks the door with
an ax and barges in surprisingly he
finds a strange looking room which turns
out to be the same one in which the
little boy from earlier was trapped here
everything is finally revealed all that
transpired in the movie was only a
visual representation inside gambier's
mind the boy who is constantly punished
was a representation of Gambier when he
was little just like the boy he also
killed both his parents in Cold Blood
while they were asleep the only
difference was that before he could
commit the unthinkable some cops broke
through the door and saved him the scene
then shifts to the present where Gambier
is inside a mental hospital waking up
from his nightmare he usually creates
Visions in his mind some of which are
very realistic this helps him forget his
gruesome past the inspiration for the
sculpture came from a journalist by the
name of ronty Who provided him with
magazines and books to stimulate his
creativity Gambier admired ratty and
made her his wife taliada in his
imagination his friends including Dan
dung are revealed to be the hospital
employees who take care of mental
patients like Gambier in the last scene
Gambier visualizes himself as a Catholic
priest helping a guy who had the same
phenomenon as him he counsels the man
not to enter his forbidden door which he
refers to as the philosophical door of
chaos the movie ends with reporter ronty
calling his friend and walking away from
the hospital when it is revealed that
the place in which Gambier is being kept
is none other than the hirosa say
building oh boy the good-spirited
holiday times continue subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching